على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه اعلن
حزب الله تنفيذ تسع عمليات ضد مواقع
اسرائيليه في الجليل الاعلى ومزارع شبع
المحتله وقال الحزب انه استهدف مقر قياده
كتيبه بيت هلال التابع للواء الاقليمي
الشرقي
769 في الجيش الاسرائيلي واضاف الحزب ان
مقاتليه قصفوا بصواريخ بركان وفلق واحد
واسلحه صاروخيه ثكنه رميم وتجمع للجنود في
محيطها و حيط موقع جل العلامه كما قصفوا
بالمدفعيه والصواريخ مواقع المرج
والرويسات العلم والسماق والرمثا في
المقابل شنت الطائرات الاسرائيليه غارات
على بلدات حوله ومروحين وطير حرفه ومنطقه
اللبون وتعرضت بلدات حدوديه عده للقصف
الاسرائيلي افاد مراسلنا بوقوع سلسله
انفجارات هزت الجليل الاعلى في محيط بلدتي
مارلوت و مسغاف عام قرب الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان واظهرت صور تصاعد اعمده الدخان
بمحيط موقع المرج العسكري الاسرائيلي وقد
واثق احد سكان المناطق الحدوديه لحظه سقوط
صاروخ من جنوب لبنان في الجليل الاعلى
تلاه تكثيف مدفعيه الجيش الاسرائيلي قصفها
لعدد من البلدات اللبنانيه ياتي ذلك عقب
اعلان جيش الاحتلال اصابه جنديين بجروح
وصفها
بالطفيفة بالله باتجاه
مرك